what's up believe nation it's a bit of a
strange different day for me let this
contain in there auntie mo and so I'm
starting a tick you want to join you
with me
[Music]
today's a holiday in Canada it's
actually Monday no you're seeing some
Sunday but what holidays it what the
holiday probably like Cinco day or
something
it's not a lot of Holly I don't know why
we're holiday I don't know why I saw
holiday today but anyway it's a holiday
and it's a Monday and we have Haydn and
I still have so Monday usually do some
work at terminal health that's my
tedious analogous we go over all the
things that we need to do for the week
and so I'm going to mix up today we've
got we've got half the day I'm going to
be meeting with Alex and then Lily
remotely and then we're going to come
back and meet these guys and go watch
what are we watching emoji emoji movie
emoji movie we're making some TV s look
at this empty parking lot there's one
car here Alex I like it I like the
hospital Alex keep it up man look this
is a super busy place typically but it's
9:00 a.m. on a Holiday Monday empty
good job Alex I'm also testing out my
new gimbal so whoa you can take some
getting used to
so this is attached my first vlog kind
of the Timo one was the first one but
it's really hip hop I was up with a new
phone
yeah I have a one plus tree yes
according 2010 what so five yeah so look
at the gimbal or say it in there is
let's come back up there's Nina and
honey there's Billy listen you all are
believed okay alright but still find
Alex
there is the man with the plan we went
downstairs and I filmed the empty
parking lot except for Alex's car oh
yeah the hustle and Alex hustle Holiday
Monday boom
wah-wah-wah you're gonna go meet thanks
it's good meat
so usually Alex and I go have coffee
once I'm on the tradition coffee yeah
coffee and a meeting coffee in a meeting
no more no more junk food no more junk
food for Alex that's you or me
yeah it used to be a big thing for you
too you know I had a refeed day
yesterday okay and I still lost point
one pound what you have ice cap and but
I know that when I hear but does that
count water weight I Nina are you
ignoring me Nina
can I can I hug you
why are you upset Oh cuz of the dog
leave my TDs Nina let's go run and find
the unit testing the gimbal just in the
Kimbell Nina let me get you a coffee
okay
okay you don't want okay you hit that
tomorrow okay name is stand about your
principles now all right I have a
passionate life and I love her very much
perfect
all right let's do it extra-large one
sugar two milk we need near one skim
milk
how did we go out like how did it go as
always after the meeting I feel both
hopeful and humbled by a lot of growth
and a lot of success were having that's
that's that's that's my response I would
soon alright so I'm good let's go do
some work so it's almost 11:00 I got to
go we're going to go into TVN and I'm
going to meet with Lilly and just go
over something back she wants to get
better at the coach and I'm supposed to
be meeting her on Wednesday normally you
have a look at the camera here a meter
on Wednesday but have an appointment and
so I want to make sure I can get her
questions answered because Wednesday's
she was full up on coaching and she
wants to feed back to having a better
coach normally we meet here at EVMs or
my place but she has to drive in two
hours to get here and because I was only
going to be here for an hour to talk to
her
she want to make that Trek which I
totally appreciate and I guess she
didn't want to spend time with this guy
she didn't wanna shooting yeah what she
didn't well right Lilly Lilly thumbs up
for the pitch I'm an entertainer people
want it fun time around me okay oh wait
they wants the time I don't know if
they'll be productive around me but they
will be interesting hashtag go long as
well as long that makes me feel long
right
[Music]
here's my gimbal guys so this is my 1
plus 5 and then the new symbol so if I
just like that I just like tap it if I
just don't
well what you get as a test don't break
it I'm not look at that there's our sign
family for one word have I shown you
soon a wife as I showed you guys the
studio so we've got the helpers these
are our helpers and assistants you
recognize this one here you recognize
Harry right there's Nina for me okay
it's not about you Alex okay here we
have our board China that salsa is where
we and then the students take different
notes and they put up what they what
they feel about PBS where we become
legends I like that one where we become
legends to grow and be closer to my
mates and then over here we've got a
little library which is we can drop off
books and other people can use them into
the thrown them away we've got our big
speakers and disco lights for our big
parties and then we've got our calendar
here
hey Alex we need a big calendar still
says July oh that Oh August 1 there we
go okay so this has our events our
parties with some quotes on the side now
it's interesting and this is where we
work I would drink a game material right
now and you miss it right I was being
Emma's out of town
right now right whenever I see it work
it's sort of like at the top belong or
well your one we're to believe the long
path of half how do we make your life
better
I've got that kitchen lives Alex with
every moment so we going to hop on to a
live stream do a hangout with Lily since
she's not coming in and help her with
her coaching see how it goes
haha hello
you got me yes yes you're moving it goes
good good it's nice it's nice out today
how to good call it Lily
yep
look to the main part like this how will
they write their name yeah dude inside
writing first day class another
experiment we're trying dr. Lilly going
to now go find mean and Haydn recover
from the Seberg you do look a little
pale look a little pale into doing that
go more wider than you look normally
what pretty my matching my drawstring
you are please he carries that people
thing to tell me okay thanks man
calculator so in the car started feeling
really high
I feel bad cuz the kids I really want to
go to the movies I mean that's going to
take them to go watch the movie I
haven't been sick and say it once this
year besides the beginning though it's
not something I'm used to anymore but
this we'll see what happens when we go
lie down relax a bit and hopefully feel
better soon so this vlog can continue
going to get the thermometer see what
temperature is
[Music]
I don't know you know lie down hopefully
feel better oh I have a map for a couple
hours feeling better
groggy I wonder if I had she got sick or
just didn't get a lot of sleep last
night was rough I was up every hour
waking up in maybe just my body reacting
to it guess we'll see how the rest of
the day goes but I just realized it's
almost four o'clock
I haven't eaten anything yet just had a
coffee with Alex that is still in the
fridge to them to finish it in the
protein bar
Angelina made me some eggs and spinach
for breakfast so four o'clock I'm going
to eat I'm sure delaying eating for so
long has not been great either
mmm still name is dr. kids to watch the
movie to come back soon I guess I'm to
do something to say thank you because
she has three three kids all that
kidding them is two cousins so we've got
clothes around here and I think what I'm
gonna do is clean up Nina comes home to
a nice clean place
she loves cleanliness I'll take the
garbage out and then politicals make for
happier Nina Nina desserts
[Music]
alright I'm done cleaning up Nina is
still not home yet the time is it 4:30
ish for 30 ish so hopefully she's going
to be excited to come to a nice clean
place and until she gets home I'm gonna
do some work somebody's home I was just
about to do some work with you come home
oh wow what a clean place this is mean
that is a little tough stuff to kind of
deal with all the kids
he met with love you
touken smells really good nina what's
happening here hey big ii yummy screen
here hold on oh no my gimbal is messed
up there kids yay Minah
what yeah
the third oh you gonna take a stand
healthy dinner Thank You Nina we
appreciate you Nina believe nation give
the big thumbs up to Nina I like your
shirt
[Music]
yeah you gotta believe in yourself Nina
has some good news
what's up Nina never someone have your
stick in Japan look at this
that is a meal yeah
Thank You Nina thank you for looking
after me